bravo d'arrivée bonjour review 30 ans de
mandats locaux
une connaissance aiguë de la
circonscription et de ses habitants
c'est sans doute ce qui a permis
l'élection de johann corneloup pour sa
première campagne des législatives
en tout cas c'est sa conviction nous
l'avons martelé entre les deux tours
puisque le slogan de campagne entre les
deux tours c'était une députée de chez
nous avec vous et pour vous et je crois
que ça résume très bien mon engagement
nous avons fait des rencontres
citoyennes nous avons fait des visites
d'entreprises nous avons fait des
visites d'exploitations agricoles et
autres et nous sommes allés au contact
de
de nos concitoyens je pense que ceci a
été apprécié et c'était l'intérêt qu'on
leur portait à quelque part en devenant
député à 57 ans est pharmacienne de
métier obtient là son poste le plus
prestigieux
elle qui a commencé par être conseillère
municipale de saint bonnet de joux en
1986 puis adjointe à la mairie avant
d'en prendre la tête en 2014
je pense qu'aujourd'hui mon expérience
c'est vraiment un atout pour siéger à
l'assemblée nationale parce que voilà il
ya il ya un grand grand nombre de choses
que je connais parfaitement bien et qui
me serviront pour pour étudier des
situations pour étudier les textes et
pour voir leurs répercussions
parmi les projets phares de ces
dernières années celui de la maison
médicale créée en 2006 la première du
département pour lutter contre la
désertification médicale et pour
l'emploi des combats qu'elle compte bien
poursuivre cette fois ci à l'assemblée